they're traveling god-knows-where by
foot no home no nothing behind him you
know and in front of him so it was just
and then I was supposed to tell
something in the camera I'm like guys
like now I mean I can't speak you know I
can't speak because it's just one of
these things that breaks your heart and
I remember it was were suppose a year
and a half ago it was just just recently
I mean when the whole Syria Syria war
started yeah it was it was it was a huge
thing in Europe because probably third
or a quarter or third of the country
just left he imagined you he's twelve
million people in Syria and was three or
four million people left the country
crazy you know and probably even more
now today because they lost homes they
lost their lives they lost their you
know close ones what they're going to do
I went to visit one of those kind of
locations that was offered from a city
as as a resting place as shelters homes
you know like temporary homes for for
the people that are passing through and
and it was one of the hotels in it in
town in Belgrade and they they they gave
them the whole lobby area the whole you
know kind of floor so as I as I come in
and I'm supposed there's a camera I
think it was CNN and you know the couple
other cameras and and they wanted me to
record a message you know for people
being there you know to ask for help to
raise funds you know to to help you know
refugees and to build homes for them and
so forth and and and as I came in and
then see you know you know different
rooms there is a play room then there is
a resting room and so forth and the look
on these people's faces was something
that was you know Wow boom right away
first impression was like pain
insecurity devastation sadness it's just
all this all these emotions and just
there they were flat you know literally
never fly they were like they didn't
know what's happening I mean they're
like okay we're here now but where are
we walking where are we going what's
gonna happen where is our life tomorrow
so as I'm walking into this small area
play area for for children there are
plenty of children there so I I observe
them you know for a little bit and then
and then one of the volunteers there you
know it tells me why don't you join them
you know try to so I I didn't know how
to react
yeah honestly I was there I didn't want
to you know I wanted to be with them but
at the same time I don't want to be in
their space because you know I could I
could feel the emotions I could feel
what they're going through so so I start
playing around and and and then ten
minutes later is you know I've really
got into it you know children and it was
a couple of children around me and we
started you know playing with toys and
and what are you know measuring things
and whatever it was it was really cool
and and and then somebody you know it
taps my shoulder and it was one of the
the people from UNICEF and she came with
with a mother of a child that I was
playing with and she was a girl there
was probably not even two two and a half
years old yeah and and and she told me
she told me her mom came her to pick her
up and it's it's time to go and and I
thought to myself it's still today's I
thought to myself where they're gonna go
you know what's kind of what's gonna
happen
I mean it's sorry I just it's it's it's
even today it's yes it's just so
emotional you know because I don't know
where did where they went you know it's
it's like having this this is this girl
and mom taking taking a boy who was six
seven years old in this little girl and
and they're you know that they're
traveling God knows where by foot no
home no nothing behind him you know and
in front of him so it was just and then
I was supposed to tell something in the
camera I'm like guys like now I mean I
can't speak you know I can't speak
because it's just one of these things
that breaks your heart you know right
it's just
who sorry that's that's what that's what
that's what war does that's what war
does but at the same time you know at
the same time I'm really grateful that
I've been through that through this
experience through you know Wars and 90s
and and all these things because it made
me more human it made me more connected
with with other people and I'd like to
look back to it as as much as it hurts
me I'd like to go back to it and
understand that what I have in life and
how fast I can lose all of that if I
don't appreciate it if I'm not living in
the present and and knowing that there
are people like that even today going
through all of this and ask being in
this in this incredible general life and
and and having this fortune to be
successful and to be to be hurt as well
you know everything that we say you know
there are thousands of millions of
people following you myself you know
children that there looking up to us and
then saying okay I mean this is
something that I can use to to be better
and I want to be like him so I think
having having this in my subconscious
see all these experiences in the past
and never forgetting about that keeps me
grounded keeps me aware that everything
I say is heard you know in these places
that that really need your advice they
need your help they need your light so
you know it's all about sharing that
light and sharing that love raise your
standard it's not one drop of most
self-worth depends on your it's suppose
to mean I don't ever give up I'd have to
be
dead or completely incapacitated hey
believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten rows of
success I have a very special secret
video for you these are the individual
clips that I have personally learned the
most from and applied to my life and my
business check the link in description
for details